فخامه الرئيس يجيبني رئيس جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمول معالي
الحضور والكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
يسرني باسم سيدي خالد الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود حفظه
الله ونرحب بكم جميعا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
التعاون لتحقيق النماء
اليوم في ظل تحديات حديثه تواجه المنطقه
بالعالم وظروف استثنائيه وتحتم علينا
تفعيل العمل الجماعي مشترك لمواجهه هذه
التحديات
وانطلاقا من الاهداف الساميه والغايات
التي بني عليها مجلس التعاون بدون الخليج
مستندا الى عمق العلاقه والصداقه
التاريخيه التي تربطنا مع تربط بلداننا مع
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه فاننا
في النغماتنا هذه تؤسس الانطلاق تاريخيه
تاريخي جديد العلاقه بين الصين والسعوديه
تعدل تعميق التعاون مع جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه في جميع المجالات والى التنسيق
وجهات النظر هي القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه تعتبر دوله مجلس التعاون جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه شركه اساسيه مهمه
ثمار ايجابيه لهذه الشراكه على مصالحنا
مشتركه وعلى امن منطقتنا واستقرارها وان
النمو الاقتصادي المتسارع والتطورات
والتقنيه الكبير الذي وصلت اليه جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه تحت قياده فخامه الرئيس
يجيبهم قصه نجاح تتجلى في مكانه الصين
الرائده الاقتصاديه العالميه وتولد
الاهميه
الصين الشعبيه بهذه الجهود لتعظيم مكاسب
هذه الشراك كما تتطلع دون مجلس التعاون
وتبادل الخبرات
وخلق شركات متنوعه في الخطوط طموح لدول
مجلس ونشيد وتطور متسارى في العلاقه
الخليجيه الصينيه وبالتنوع الواضح في
مجالات التعاون الاستراتيجي بين الجانبين
كالتجاره والاستثمار والطاقه والتعليم
والبحث العلمي والبيئه والصحه وتطلع دول
مجلس لرفع مستوى هذا التعاون الى افاق
ارحب كما نشيل الارتفاع الملحون في حجم
التبادلات التجاريه بين دول مجلس التعاون
والجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه التي تتوقع ان تستمر في النمو بعد
تناول المفاوضات الخاصه باقامه منطقه
تجاريه حره بين الجانبين وذلك تسيير تجاره
وحكمه المصالح التجاريه متبادله بما يتيح
الاستفاده القصوى من فرص الاستثمار واحده
وتحميل توسع مجالات الشراكه بين الجانبيه
وتتمن دول مجلس الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
بينها وبين جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه وتشييد
بخطوط العمل المشترك للمده 22 23 22 27
للاهميتها في تعزيز امطار استراتيجي
للتعامل بين الجانبين
وتهتمدوا المجلس بالعمل بالعمل
عمليه التحديات العالميه بما في ذلك الامن
الغذائي وتحسين وتحسين تكامل ثلاث سلاسل
الام العالميه وامن الطاقه
وتؤكد دول مجلس لدول خليج العربي استمرار
دول دورها همم مصدره موثوق لتلبيه
احتياجات العالم للطاقه والصين وتتمم دول
مجلسائيه الصين لطرح مبادراته مبادرات
تعنى بتنشيط مسار التعاون وتعزيز العمل
الدولي متعدد الاطراف على راسهم مبادره
اصدقاء التنميه العالميه ونشارك التفكير
مع اصدقائنا في الصين حول اهميه اعاده
توجيه تركيز المجتمع الدولي نحو التعاون
والتنميه والتنميه والمجابه التحديات
ومشتركه التي تواجه الانسانيه اصحاب
الجلاله والفخامه والسمو المعالي تستمر
دول مجلس في بدر جميع الجهود لتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه كما تدعم الحلول
السياسيه والحوار لجميع التويترات
والنزاعات الاقليميه والدوليه من منطلق
ذلك هو المسار الكثير بتحقيق السلام
والامن والازدهار كما ان هذه الغايات لا
تتحقق الا بخروج الارشاد المرتزقه من جميع
الاراضي العربيه ووقفه التدخلات الخارجيه
في شانها وفي ختام سرنا تقدم بشكل جزيلا
لجمهوريه الصين بقياده على السائل المستمر
لتعميقه العلاقات الصينيه الخليجيه
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]